paulo espino has been called up and will
get the start for the nats in the last
of this four game series that news
because steven strasberg has been placed
on the injured list as of this morning
with right shoulder inflammation
there's a fastball that's driven deep to
right field josh rojas gets it started
well that'll get him going yeah
a lead off home run diamondback strike
first we said they need to get the lead
off man on base he got on all the bases
that time josh rojas good to see him
hitting the ball hard again after a
great cactus league has had trouble
getting on track
and he hits one high in the air out to
dead center victor robles
swinging the ground ball right side into
the shift out there is josh harrison and
shallow right the throw to ryan
zimmerman
two away here at the top of the first
hit
not the breaking ball and david dunks it
into right field there's a two ounce
single
swing and a miss on a 90 heater next up
the nats who have the highest team
batting average in the national league
starting pitcher for the diamondbacks
it's the lefty madison bumgarner said
last week he did not have the words to
truly describe his extremely frustrating
start to the season
there's that cutter down and in good
start for mad bum
[Applause]
did he hold
what a walk
you know sometimes it's hard to get
excited about a walk in the first inning
that was one heck of an advantage well
yeah i mean a lot of people say you know
free pass there was nothing free about
this pass and the battle he just had was
madison bumgardner first he had
got him to chase a high fastball at 92
second strikeout for bumgarner
soto takes off again
backhand stopped by nick ahmed and no
way to get castro soto heads for third
and he is out of there
soto makes the final out of the inning
at third base trying to grab an extra 90
feet
and there's a lead off walk
thank you sir this is going to be close
ryan zimmerman knows this ballpark
doesn't he
nice play right up against the rail
the key is getting there so you know
where you're at not floating with it
and nick heath welcome to the
diamondbacks he knocks it into center
he's one for one in sedona red nick
heath
strike three call
bumgardner gave up on it has their word
with james hoy
as if to say that wasn't a strike and i
hope you give me that one
fastball all around the zone
and he follows up with a curveball gets
his third strikeout in the first six
batteries
fastball driven out to center heath has
got it madison works a one two three
second and again leads it one nothing
and a ball drilled out to center road
lays back
and it missed a homer by maybe two feet
and he's out by a wide margin at second
base
victor robles with an absolute seed from
deep center come on is drupal you do
better than that he's got a cannon
you were just hoping this one stayed in
the yard right
and when he hit the top of the fence
maybe it's surprised as drupal cabrera
too what a throw by victor robles on the
fly
castro's busy he made the tag and now he
gets an assist
paulo espino he's going after these guys
[Music]
the ball and that's strikeout number
four madison has now retired five in our
own six of seven
trey 28 for
72 coming into the game
he didn't bust him inside that time
see
you
later
more than halfway up the blue seats
and the game is tied on trey's third of
the year
109 423
world two out lightning from trade
turner to tie this one up carson kelly
starts off the fourth against paulo
espino
carson kelly down the line carson kelly
gone and the diamondbacks get the lead
right back
carson's third it's two to one oh he
smoked that one
fastball at 88.
the first batter in the fourth carson
kelly makes it two to one
and everybody's swinging
schwarber on the run
all right back in the dugout
threw him a strike
and the pitcher slash hitter is upset
again is paulo done i think he's done he
just gave the baseball to davey and
he'll get a nice hand as he comes off
matches his career long four and a third
innings and here comes clay
oh sinker down and into the lefty
that's a good pitch
two down here in the fifth
looking for his first rbi
oh nowhere to go on that one that made a
loud sound as it appeared to get him in
the foot
chase to curveball up in the zone
we've played five innings at nationals
park and it's two to one
diamondbacks and the d-backs haven't had
really much to do with juan soto all
weekend
two more walks today
jammed that ball goes spinning by the
mound that's an infield hit
and starlin castro with two infield
knocks is two for three
fastball in right to ahmed short where
they get the force on castro and ginkel
gets us through six with a 2-1 lead
and
i'm liking nick heath i'm on board
two for three what a start
he's off and running pitch is a fast
ball and did they get him from behind it
looks like it
another bullet from yon gomes
and that's castro on the tag
like when they got low castro yesterday
trying again and missed and it's a two
out walk
second walk issued by both and here's
pavon smith over three
fastball is punched down the line that's
a fair ball
and rojas is on the run here he comes
around third
josh rojas is in there it's an rbi
double for pavon smith and it's three to
one diamondbacks
david today is one for three hitting the
first ceiling lines this one into right
center that's a base hit and that's
extra bases all the way to the wall over
to get it is roblox and peralta's into
second base with a double they're up by
two the 1-0 pitch
swaying and a drive hits it pretty deep
right soto is under it and makes a catch
here comes peralta and he will score on
the throw to the plate and it's a four
to one ball game soto had a little
trouble candy when he grabbed for that
baseball
and top of the order for the nationals
so this is the inning to do something
with trey turner leading off
turner
big fly right center
c
u
later
he buggy whipped one to left
then he stayed on it and hit it out to
right center
that was a pro at bat
folks back to the slider
oh that's a thing little tapper
rojas aboard for the third time today
[Applause]
maybe they're going to walk david
intentionally here to get to the
right-hander
or rather carson kelly the first one on
the way
kelly a breaking ball throw back to
first and probably they throw it away
and that's going to get a run home raw
scores and problem will go to third well
they threw down to first base trying to
pick off peralta and they threw it away
and it's 5-2 d-backs
he's walked three consecutive batters
one was intentional but now they're
loaded for ahmed it was over four
one and two
[Applause]
got him looking
nick ahmed not happy last-hitting when
he got called out and this time either
crying on the 1-0 pitch to stevenson
swung on and hitting the air to right
paving smith is under it and right field
comes in a couple of steps makes a catch
and the diamondbacks have won the final
game of this four game series by a score
of five to two they split the four game
set madison bumgarner gets his first win
of the year and a save goes to stephon
crichton